they are not closing our damn plant
without one hell of a fight the
best-known face of canadian labor former
long-time head of unifor jerry diaz now
mired in scandal the investigation found
that diaz accepted money from a supplier
of covet 19 rapid test kits that he had
introduced to employers of uniform
members unifor alleges dyess accepted 50
thousand dollars from a test supplier he
allegedly gave half to a colleague who
filed a complaint dyess released a
statement shortly before unifor revealed
the details this past december my life
took a remarkable turn for the worse
when i was confronted with a
debilitating sciatic nerve issue it's
hard for me to say this but my coping
mechanism has been painkillers sleeping
pills and alcohol these factors have
impaired my judgment in recent months i
am entering a residential rehabilitation
facility last month dice went on medical
leave then announced his retirement
earlier this month he did not respond to
interview requests from global news
unifor is canada's biggest private
sector union and represents some global
news employees the union says what
happened is an isolated incident asked
whether police will be investigating we
have sought outside counsel throughout
this process to guide us to obviously
getting an external investigator the
police have enough to go ahead and
implement criminal charges and it's yet
to be determined but it would not
surprise me at this time because the
amount is so significant daya stands
charged with violating unifor's code of
ethics in his statement he said he quote
was always guided by the principles set
out in our constitution the next step
will be a hearing but so far daya says
he hasn't participated in the
investigation on his doctor's advice
abigail beeman global news ottawa